hello everyone I do hope your Saturday
went well and that you are having an
excellent Sunday because here we have
the fourth game will be showing from the
ninth round of the 2013 candidates
tournament it's Boris Gelfand vs. levin
aragon before we start with the game as
usual we do have some photos to check
out so here it is somewhere during the
opening standard position get fun with
his glass of water and an espresso and
our union with glass of water and the
hidden thermos bottle to the right of
him we have another photo I have a very
nice close-up of gelfand it's like he's
saying it's like he's saying really
really you're gonna play that against me
but could be you know as I don't know
the game day it does seem like he's
actually saying that and here we have a
nice close-up of of Levin trying to
figure out his way out of out of the
opening so that being seen let's see
this game Geffen has the white pieces
and he opens with d4 I will have knife
to have six c4 and a six and let me just
have to mute the sound so you don't hear
double sounds Knight to f3 and the d5
once again we transpose into the Queens
gambit declined Knight to c3 Bishop to
e7 Bishop to f4 and now we have castles
III Knight B to d7 Bishop to e2 c6
castles and knights to h5 going after
the advance Bishop on f4 Bishop to e5
and now f6 it seems like this would be a
very nice opportunity to grab the bishop
pair for example my captors but here
Griffin would actually play D captures
on e5 and now these double cons are
actually preventing the knight any from
escaping from h5 here black wood as g4
is a terrible threat black can lose a
knight here black would have to play g6
and then Knight will go to g7 but it's
weakening the Kings position and there's
really no reason to do this so Oregon
doesn't isn't interested in this he
plays f6
we have Bishop to g3 and here definitely
Aragon could capture the bishop but
instead he proceeds further with f5 get
friend again goes Bishop to e5 and now
Knight back to f6 and here and get one
goes h3 if Aaron doesn't want to capture
the bishop perhaps get fund will retreat
it all the way to h2 now but here Aragon
does capture it Knight captures only
five will have Knight captures and
Knight to d7 f4 this is a standard theme
when you're playing against against this
defense Knight captures pawn captures on
an e5 and Bishop to g5 attacking the
weak III pawn here Queen to d2 get some
defense the pond Bishop to d7 it's very
hard to actually develop the light
square bishop which is often the case in
this defense onions idea is the Bishop
to d7
- eh - f7 and later on maybe it can even
come to h5 to be exchanged so Bishop to
d7 rook 8 2 c1 rook the c8 and a3 now
King to h8 we have B 4 and Bishop we ate
our own proceeds with his plan Bishop to
d3 now the bishop is no longer
controlling h5 so worship to h5 by our
owner will definitely be an idea
rook the c7 we have nice to eat - Bishop
to h5 and now Knight to f4 attacking the
bishop on h5 Bishop captures pawn
captures and rook to d7 and this is this
is really the critical moment in the
game here again it does seem like Aragon
solved all of his opening problems he's
preparing D captures on c4 which will
open up the D file and the Queen rook
battery will be very strong here against
the weak D pawn and here you could play
c5 close up the position and then
transfer the game all the way to the
Queen side maybe push a 4 B 5 but here
gauge once teaches us a very very
valuable lesson instead of preventing
your opponent from achieving his plan
rather you should allow it you should
allow it if it doesn't work so here get
a funk plays Queen to e3 but to play
Queen to e3 he had to look very far into
the
future which which he did very nicely he
captures on c4 was played we have Bishop
captures on c4 and now you have to
decide do you capture on d4 and you
allow Bishop captures on e6 or you play
rook to e8 now you're defending the e
pawn and there's really no way for white
to stop rook captures on d4 so why did
the guys want to play this you can't
protect it with the rook because Bishop
is guarding the d1 square if our onion
played rook to e8 which he didn't get
offense plan was actually d5 it's a very
nice move and now if see captors and if
I've done Bishop to b5 wins the exchange
and on the other hand if you play it
captures then get France planner was
Bishop to d3 attacking the f5 point and
here guys once said that which which you
can all check out there is an interview
would guess one day after this game
Irena was not present in the interview
as he did have to do a drug test but you
can check it out there will be a link in
the description below and after
something like d4 couldn't you have two
and I look to f8 the defending the f5
pawn here get a get one said that after
rook to c5 he will have more than enough
compensation for the pawn as black that
doesn't really have any activity he will
double up on the C file and then later
on push a for and b5
so Aragon agreed would get fun he did
not he did not protect the d6 pawn
instead he played rook after sandy for
immediately
we have Bishop captures and now Bishop
to f7 and here comes a movie elephant
had to see when he decided to go into
this variation of course what's the idea
you want to exchange the bishops and it
seems that there's no way for you to
actually capture the f5 pawn because if
Bishop captures then Bishop to c4 this
attacks your piece and also the rook and
f1 so at least you will lose the
exchange here but this was this was
exactly what get fun played get from the
dead capture the pawn and are indeed
play Bishop to c4 so here's the question
why did why did why did the guy from the
Wow this your Bishop is under attack if
you move it you're going to
Bishop captures an f1 rook captures and
after Queen to b6 there's I mean those
are nice pawns but there's really no
compensation for the exchange it would
be a winning position for Aragon so why
did you get funds allow this this Bishop
to c4 idea
so it's an it's an excellent position
for you to pause the video and try to
figure out the move that Aragon
overlooked and that allowed guys want to
gain great advantage in this game so I
will give it a couple of seconds as
usual feel free feel free to try it I
know it's Sunday you know everyone's
lazy on Sunday but you know do do try it
you're gonna feel very nice about
yourself so for those who found it
congratulations you just found a move
are in your midst and for those of you
who just wanna enjoy the show in this
position guess one played east six and
what's the idea of e-cigs how does e six
prevent black from actually capturing
here
well if rook captures here then e seven
is coming and notice that the queen is
guarding the rook and before but you can
never allow a point to be pushed all the
way to twenty eight so Queen would have
to block it and after you capture here
there's really no way for you to capture
the rook on f1 and there's there's
really no good move here for black if
you captured Queen comes to d8 and now
black really doesn't have a move Queen
captures is a great threat if you
capture then it's it's checkmate there's
really nothing to do here so after this
East six move RN saw that there's no way
for him to actually capture the bishop
he played Queen to d6 and here what do
you do here here girlfriend finds
another brilliant move he plays rook F
to e1 he offers his light-square bishop
yet again as to what happens if you if
you capture it now if rook captures an
f5 do you see how white wins this game
another excellent puzzle for you win
this with white aha if if black would
capture on f5 so I will give it a couple
of seconds once again so for those of
you who found it
congratulations you really know how to
how to use your Sundays and for those
who just want to enjoy the show
the move you have to find is not e seven
if you found these seven then you would
not win this game because black can
actually defend this after Bishop to f7
give up a little material but then
everything is okay you promote Oh Queen
captures Queen captures and now you have
looked to f8 and this was the whole
point of our engines playing Queen to d6
so the Queen from d6 would be guarding
f8 so here the material is completely
equal there's really nothing for four
White's to push for here so after rook
captures on f5 the idea you had to find
was rook captures on c4 eliminating the
bishop that was the whole defensive idea
and after rook captures now you push e7
and now there is no defense I have to
rope captures you simply bring another
Queen into the game and after rook to f8
blocking now Queen to e7 it's two queens
and the rook against the rooks and the
Queen are completely winning position so
of course Aragon saw this after rook to
e1 there is yet there is no way to
capture a bishop once again so rook to
e8 it's time to block that passed pawn
east 7a now comes from Bishop to f7 and
rook to c5 we have g6 attacking the
bishop Bishop to g4 and now h5 attacking
the bishop once again and here - for the
third time offers his light square
bishop he plays f5 and what do you do
here well if you play H captures on g4
then comes Queen to h6 check you have to
move the King King to g8 now comes F
captures on g6 and of course the threat
is a queen to h7 check followed by Queen
to f7 checkmate so you have to capture
the pawn if you play Bishop captures
then you get R up to g5 and there is no
defense against rook captures on g6 and
even if you don't capture by the bishop
if you play Queen captures then again
rook to g5 wins the Queen and the game
so a very nice idea by gated fund this
f5 move so once again it's not possible
to capture the light square Bishop King
the g7 was played we have F captures on
g6 Bishop captures on g6 and now Bishop
captures on h5 rope to d3 aragon attacks
against Queen here and now comes Queen
to e5
this comes with check there was a there
there was an even nicer
move the forces matters that is Queen to
g5 actually and after Queen to g5 black
black has just lost let's say Queen to
d4 check King moves and after you track
upload more checks Queen checks Rock
blocks now you attack the d5 rook simply
Bishop captures on g6 Queen captures and
now rook captures on d5 you cannot
capture the Queen because rook will
capture back so you have pawn captures
and now Queen captures the pawn on e7 is
protected you're up three points Europe
I mean it's five points against two so a
completely winning game for white but
it's interesting here you can see how
strong elephant is that he played Queen
to e5 check and that he knows that this
this end game when the Queen's come off
the board is winning for him so Queen
captures only five we had rook captures
on e5 and now Bishop captures on h5 rook
captures on h5 and now rook captures an
a3 so getting this up only one point but
he knows that this is winning rook to a5
we had rock to t3 and now rook comes to
e4 rook attacks the pawn on e7 now comes
rock to g4 check King to h6 and now rook
to f6 with check King to h7 and now rook
the f7 with check King to h6 rock G to
g7 and now the king is caraway cut off
from the entire board he has to stick
all only to the H file and the pawn on
e7 is protected
we have rook to d1 check King to h2 and
now rook to f1 offering a trade of rooks
Rock to h7 check King to g6 and now rook
H to g7 once again King h6 and Brooke to
h7 repeating a move a couple of times
the position King g6 and now rook F the
g7 we have King to f6 and now h4 we have
King to e6 rock to g4 and King back to
f5 came to g3 defending the rook rook to
e1 and now rook to a4 check King e6 we
have h5 now pushing the passed pawn rook
captures on e7 rook captures on e7 and
King captures on e7 here Kevin saw that
it's okay to give up the D pawn now
because now the H bond will be
stoppable a king to h4 we have v6
preparing C 5 H 6 rock to H 1 check King
to g5 and now King to e6 King to g6 we
have came to e5 and here rock to f5
check was played and it was in this
position at 11 arjan resigned the game
so a very nice win bye bye Boris Gelfand
a beautiful piece sacrifice well it's
not really a piece Accra fry since the
bishop could never be captured but a
wonderful idea that Queen to e3 move
followed by e6 that's really really good
fun shows that he does belong here in
the candidates tournament the 2013
candidates tournament
what if you resign well the black king
is in check you do have to play a move
after something like King to e6 g4 is
coming after black try something g5 is
coming and after c5 b captures black
will try to push the beep on and perhaps
the a point as this is this is his only
counter play
but then h7 is coming and after before
since black doesn't really have a useful
move f4 will rock to it for will win the
game so black will either captured the
rook and then white gets a queen or
black will move the rook and then white
will eliminate the only country play
black head so yeah after this rook to f5
check iron and resigned the game and a
very nice one bye bye Boris Gelfand
so let's see that for one more time so
this is I don't know at what point is
this this photo was taken but really
really seems like girlfriend is not very
impressed with our enhance play and as I
don't want us to forget we do have the
standings after round 9 so let's check
it out
Carson is now the sole leader after nine
rounds with six points then Aragon with
five and a half after losing this game
to Boris Gelfand Kramnik following with
five then we have Greece Chuck and Boris
Gelfand with four and a half Peter
Svidler would for vastly bunch of with
three and a half and then team or a job
of with three so quite a different
standings since a couple of rounds ago
so that's the game
gay fans versus Iran from around
the 2013 candidates tournament I do hope
you enjoyed it I would like to thank
Matteo soon Itsuki and then in
McCullough for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon with a couple of nice
games from around 10 over the 2013
candidates tournament thank you all and
I'll see you soon